greetings from podcast ville happy
fourth of July - you [__] filthy
Savage [__] the Church of
what's happened now is brought to you by
CBD line listen finding a reliable CBD
company is [__] like bullying you know
Pete you follow me but those days are
over with I mean everywhere I Drive in
California there's a flag CBD I went to
a 7-eleven there they put a little Isis
guys selling the CBD Isis it's [__]
CBDs everywhere but don't buy that [__]
listen you want a reliable source you
want a reliable CBD that works
CBD Lyon calm is the CBD you're looking
for whether it's chatot vape cartridges
teaches CBD Lyon is the way to go go to
CBD lying right dot-com right now and
check out the third party lab results
yourself right now the church family
gets 20% off when you put in church at
checkout at CBD Lyon dot-com the church
is also brought to you by my family on
it alpha brain shroom tech room tech
sport shroom tech immune the protein
powder I mean listen when it comes to
supplements on it is number one how do I
know there's that [__] live in it I
damaged my body for thirty [__] years
now I live on on it my alpha brains on
fire they give you a hundred percent if
you don't like the product who does that
nobody that's why I go to Hana calm
right now impress in church and get 10%
off your order of supplements delivered
right to your door who's better than
haunted
nobody kick this [__] muley it's
the fourth of [__] July you bad
[__] sista fourth the [__] in
July we did it again we made it to
another [__] fourth now and you got
all your [__] fingers hopefully it's
gonna be a beautiful day you with your
family at the beach you're at a [__]
pool or maybe you just home you want to
stay home we don't give a [__] about
what's going on there sometimes I don't
blame me it might be too hot people
busting your balls firecrackers I hate
fireworks your poor [__] cat dog
hiding because it sounds like Charles
Bronson it's outside with a [__]
machine gun with dead Mexicans you got
to live out here for a few days they
don't stop the [__] guns
I'm surprised it's very quiet it's July
1st and I haven't heard [__]
cuz usually you start on the 26th trying
out [__] putting in bottles see what
type of damage it does so on the 4th you
got all your [__] tools annoying I
ain't mad at you this is your first year
and then that's your neighborhood or a
second here in this label yeah I've been
in this neighbor for 10 [__] years oh
yeah we went a little bit away so I
could somebody brought I've heard it
it's all the same [__] you haven't heard
dick if we're gonna hear anything in
here in here because we're closer to
Allah or they even got a little Mexican
joint over here where you could dance
the night away if you'd like they got
bands yeah bring em up Isis [__] goes
in there nice Isis nice [__] people
I've seen when I get my car wash
really I've seen ice over there [__]
knocking on the door early in the
afternoon giving them a notice that they
showing up tonight
immigration watch them scatter in the
old days that would just go immigration
and people would be jumping windows and
be [__] beautiful
you never seen them I have a friend
immigration watching scatter he would
pull up to a bunch of Spanish people
that was sitting on a block and he was
yelling at him immigration you just yell
migration to go watch them scatter oh my
god buddy Roger Holloway I called them
what can they call them yesterday
Goomba yeah that's the guy who said
Macumba but anyway this is a solo
podcast and I want to talk to you guys
about a few things you know I I got
anywhere from 75 to 100 [__] emails a
week on Facebook and Messenger
I find [__] the church you know and it's
so funny how yes I'll be one advice in
comedy some people want advice on drugs
and people don't know what to do it's
pretty interesting the emails I get but
the email I've been getting frequently I
guess I haven't spoken about lately and
people want to know about is my eldest
daughter you know let me talk to you
people about something Mouse before that
they don't get to that I went to take my
young daughter yesterday to her
self-defense class and I was sitting
outside and
girl came to get a brochure and when she
came out she walked up to me and asked
me if I was Joey I did yeah she shook my
hand she goes I didn't move here from
Houston I'm a comic and I've been here
for about two years and to ask you a few
questions I wasn't sure you know I was
just sitting there
my wife was next to I go sit down and
you know ask them whatever you want and
she was asking me about that she had
done Kevin Hart special one of the Kevin
Hart shows on Comedy Central
she did a movie and she played like a
Shelley maybe ten scenes in the movie
sky out of action and the movie will
they do great cast and she just got
something else some of the show she
opened up for Mike Epps uh uh I don't
have a theatre or something like that
and then my user again and she goes you
know that you get all these things from
time to time but that she wanted it for
it to move faster you know and I asked
like are you frustrated right now and
she's like a little bit and I go you
know what I was frustrated for 20
[__] years
like frustration is something it's not
it's connected to have a little bit of
anger it's connected to a little bit of
just being disoriented but when you're
frustrated that's one of the worst
[__] feelings in the world cuz it
doesn't go away from I was frustrated
from like 93 to 2007 I was living my
life very frustrated because I couldn't
figure out the the path you know I was
getting close to the path but I couldn't
figure it out you know he's getting
close to the bad dumb one that figured
that I just had eliminate the coke out
of my life and that's what it was that
was the last of frustrations you know
and I was frustrated frustrated for the
same reason you you guys are frustrated
your job you know things aren't going
well enough they hired this guy instead
of you
this guy got promoted instead of you why
is this guy getting this and I do this
this guy's getting a lot more money than
me and I sell more tickets him they were
just so many little frustrations that I
had you know what was going on with my
daughter of my ex
wife that's [__] frustrating you know
I I lost $200,000 they're easily an
attorney bills for what at the end for
what you know what was the point of
going through all those motions for the
result that we got but when you're
frustrated it's also the result that
you're not doing something right and you
don't want to come to terms with it
that's what frustration is that you're
cutting [__] corners instead of doing
the goddamn work now there's nothing and
you think you're doing well or whatever
but you know you could be doing better
and you can't put your finger on you
know you're cutting corners you're
cutting corners in your life and one day
you know you could this I was very
frustrated for years then I got into
calmly and I lost 50% of the frustration
I had because I wasn't in the work force
anymore more that's very frustrating
being in the work force I know that you
guys that have day jobs and you know
you're into them and you are college
educated or maybe you're not college
educated
it's [__] frustrating having a day
job it's okay for a while then something
happens and you hate it and then you
like it again but it's it's it's similar
to comedy it's it's a lot of life and
comedy exactly the same that's why I
call it a journey cuz you're gonna be
frustrated but what do you do you quit
no you keep pushing along and you stay
frustrated I mean through me I just
stayed frustrated after I got into
comedy full time I was still frustrated
and then 93 was when the frustration
went away now I had a completely
different frustration which is what to
do with my ex-wife and the kid but
that's completely different you know
part of frustrations and not commitment
either you know I love these people who
go well I'm gonna do this but I'm gonna
keep my job until this happens it's
never gonna happen because you're giving
50% to this and 50% to the other so you
can't give 100% to anything in full and
in those trenches you get frustrated
because do I quit my job or do I keep
playing the violin you know do I do I do
this or do I so it's it's a constant
process it go and once it goes into your
[__] bones you cannot get rid of it
well cut you said you said that the
frustration stems from your not doing
something you're supposed to be doing
absolutely is there it does it all is
there another side of it where maybe
it's two or maybe you just started
something or maybe maybe it's not like
is there snot like is there a part of it
that you're just impatient or is it all
its impatience
part of it is impatience but the trouble
finding yourself at a particular time
for a particular period of time finding
yourself in a in a position for a long
period of time you start getting
frustrated you're sucking frustrated I'm
not doing this I'm not doing that
and the answer and the frustration is
always looking into yourself and always
going you know what life isn't fair I
get that I knew that I found that out
when I was 13 but now how can I make
life more fair in my favor it takes
somebody really like to step out of your
body and look to see where you're
slipping frustration comes from you not
doing something you're not doing
something you're supposed to be doing if
you keep putting on the back burner you
you know that's frustration that's
frustration and once you do something to
get that away you won't be frustrated no
more you're still not gonna get to that
location any quicker but now at least
you know you're gonna get there
eventually okay okay so that's the
difference if you're frustrated it's
because frustration and in your mind is
you can't wait
you cannot [__] win think about that
state I was something gonna look in your
eye and say you can't win well wait a
second Joey I wasn't looking to win but
I was looking to come in third well what
do you need to do to come in third what
needs to be done what what what is the
simple solution how can we change this
that's frustration you know so here I
was frustrated
calmly by 95 I wasn't that frustrated on
ball
I knew that time I knew I had nothing
going on when I also know because I had
nothing going on time was in my side by
95 I was probably making eight hundred
to a thousand doing comedy every month
and the rest was free but at least I was
paying my rent I was eating I would do
little hostels in time to time my gamble
with Josh wolf or sit on bets or
whatever that that game it will or extra
income or get somebody a grandma below
yeah but as far as a comic I was making
eight hundred to a thousand my fourth
year in comedy it's frustrating but how
also knew that two years earlier I was
making 200 a month in common so I knew
that the longer I stuck with it the more
money I would make and then you have a
setback month and then you get back on
the road you know I thought every month
is gonna be good not every month is
gonna be good
you know you know I'm on Weight Watchers
and for a while there I lost weight I
started lifting heavy weight I gained
weight and then I started putting on
weight again so I want to talk to this
lady where I left and she's a
nutritionist and she talked to me about
a diet she had and I knew by looking at
it I couldn't do that diet I travel I
travel and I said you know what instead
of doing the diet I'm gonna tighten up
my Weight Watchers more and that's what
I tell people with a diet or that type
of lifestyle it's one day at a time it's
you against your mind every day and
someday you win and some days you lose
I'll tell you what if you eat good for
five days and you eat men's amends for
two days you want you want you want it's
week two week last week I didn't dip
into my extra points I didn't weigh
myself I feel a little lighter I feel a
lot lighter but that was I was
frustrated you know plateau is
frustration you're not doing something
you're supposed to be [__] knowing
obviously I have no business talking
about it but just I just want to see
where you're coming from so obviously no
one's perfect and
there's certain things that you can't do
that died on the road but in a perfect
world is that diet something you should
be doing is you not doing that it's not
gonna work for me I know going into it
it's not gonna work okay I know going
it's not gonna work for me okay I just
saw the foods they wanted you to eat and
I knew it wasn't gonna work of it so I
know it's not gonna work for me with
Weight Watchers I could control it
I could eat chicken breast all day right
white rice and black beans I got eight
points you know this little thing as I
could control you're not gonna win every
day right but if you win five days on
the seven you won you did the week you
know right now it takes a lot for me to
go to a McDonald so I'm taking a lot for
me to [__] the only fast food I eat
is pizza that's young and I don't need
it from everywhere I eat it from one
certain place now but I plan my day I
know that I have seven days to go to war
but when I look at the menu I look at it
and I prepare when I go to a certain
town I know what menus they have and I
know what I could eat like to stay
within that realm but it's the same
thing with life you're not gonna win
every day of life but first you're gonna
start winning one day a week then you're
gonna start winning two days a week and
you know feel frustrated for five then
you're gonna start winning three days a
week then four days a week and listen
what are you gonna do you're gonna do
four good days a week and you're gonna
have three bad days didn't you just tell
me yesterday that baseball is weird
because you could bat 300 it's a game
based on percentages life is also based
on percentages life is also based on
percentages so what are you saying to me
Joey okay every month if you have 22
good days of eating and seven bad days
you won that means you got seven minus
22 is 15 good days of eating you've made
a little bit of progress that's how you
have to look at things there's the
progress but a little things that you
could do daily to change what's going on
in your world
you know what man I don't like this
material I'm doing wall goat schedule 22
sets in two weeks and do a comedy camp
go home every night listen to your thing
write it down and you live for it and
you'll get away plateaus mean you're not
doing something right I took a flat
domains in your life how many plateaus
if I had if it was if it was if I put
plateaus by you know though you know
when you put four lines and then the
line through it right you ever see that
it's five mistakes I've had ninety
[__] thousand plateaus you not only
plateaus like man the last ten years
maybe six or seven compared to eight
thousand I had before it's 2009 2008
since I took control of my life because
I got off the drugs but then I still
[__] make mistake off the drugs you
bet your mother's [__] [__] I did
you bet your ass I did put the
percentage of mistakes got lower and
lower so do you think it's possible to
have a mistake free of frustration free
life or no no no no what's a frustration
free life II okay we were talking about
some money today a friend of mine in
Jersey
his family chops up thirty million a
month for because they bought real
estate in the 60s and they bought really
good real estate in the sixties now I
look at a guy like you guys or whatever
and you go WOW Joey
thirty million divided by four every
month I get my dick sucked every day
what's the biggest problem when you get
thirty million dollars a month divided
by four which is what exact seven and a
half yeah like seven to have what is
your biggest problem what is your
biggest problem that you would look to
me you go Joey seven million a month
flop I would even listen to you anymore
right seven million a month you're on a
boat with three chicks you chop your
head off and you put her in a mailbox to
[__] to Mexico whatever the [__] that
I'm price charges about seven million a
month that comes into your [__]
account every month you know
even with that 7 million believe it
enough there's gonna be frustrations
you're never ever ever gonna have or a
pain free frustration free no drama free
[__] life you know when drama happens
think about it Lee change that [__]
tire it looks long and a low and don't
look loud because I I got this got it
leaf something's not right with that tie
these are mistakes you make mean you're
21 and all of a sudden two days that I
got a call from San Diego where are you
I'm at the side of the road the tire
went flat what did I tell you three days
ago to change it but you want to save
the 40 right you create your own
frustrations do you see them saying so
part of your life you create a lot of
frustrations yourself by not listening
by not taking care of something
something that's right in front of you
take care of it take care of it why wait
till tomorrow we need to take care of it
right now
I'm talking about you go to the bathroom
and all sudden you're peeing and also
you get hit with three things on water
obviously your roof is leaking you know
instead of putting spackle and checking
that you go and lay down and also you
come back two days later and your roof
is on the [__] floor in the bathroom
and you could eliminate there's so many
things you couldn't eliminate from your
life we all know that you guys are not
stupid there's things that we eliminate
when I stopped doing drugs I eliminated
80 [__] things from my mind how do I
know cuz here's where I am today I took
the time if I was thinking how I was
gonna get it who I was gonna get it from
how I was gonna get the money and I took
that same time and invested right in a
joke and calling a club owner I did all
these things when I was doing the coke
am i doing it more effectively now
obviously because I had a frustration
had that drunk I also had a frustration
of my ex-wife and my daughter big
frustration because I wasn't getting
nowhere but what happened to me in 95 in
95 for two years I fought her for
everything I had I borrowed money from
everybody
I stole what I could I robbed a few drug
dealers just I think about all these
things I did to get money
to pay an attorney so I could see you on
a Wednesday because I couldn't get her
every time you file a motion
it's another [__] ain't allowance it's
two hours you're paying the guy four
hundred and hour or two fifty an hour
whatever anything over ten thousand
hours too [__] much for those [__]
thieves so you know I'm frustrated cuz
I'm broke I'm frustrated I still found
money to do coke though right or wrong I
couldn't pay rent but I found money to
do coke
so who's the [__] problem with it's
me I'm frustrated I don't have rent
money you were jumping up and down there
and man and islands lounge though on the
table with white all over your [__]
face you know you found time you know
so all these front those type of
frustrations you know I don't have rent
money I've been telling you since the
eighth of the month to go look for a job
I've been telling you that this was
gonna happen
you don't want to find the [__] job
this day was gonna happen
what's the 30th of it what you create so
there's things frustrations that you
created in your own life with my ex-wife
and daughter for people who don't know I
had a daughter in 1990 I got the time in
91 we split up six months after that I
don't even need hindsight to tell you
this before she a month after she moved
out I knew I was gonna have problems
seeing that kid I knew that that was the
weapon she was gonna use against me I
kept trying to force myself to believe
that I had known her for too long and we
had too much history for her to do
something like that to me that was my
fault but and deep down inside I knew
that eventually I wasn't gonna see that
child for two years I did everything I
could to see that child sustained in
life but I could see where the cards are
turning I could see how I just wasn't
getting no aces in my life at all but I
wasn't doing anything to get any aces
either you felt I wasn't doing anything
to make my life better I was going to
war with her I was still snorting coke I
was still seeing crazy woman I was still
paying child support late I was still
doing all the things but I had to write
that talk [__] I never
to talk [__] I was bringing my own
frustration on but when I saw my comedy
game improving and I saw that one day I
smacked my ex-wife's boyfriend and I saw
my little daughter look like I was
frustrated that's why I smacked them
that was part that was part of the snack
I was very frustrated but I also saw
something in my behavior that day that
knew that I was the activity that keep
living frustrated or go for my dream and
deal with whatever I had to deal with
later on and I did that we haven't had
contact in probably 15 [__] years
does it kill me
it killed me for a long time now today
honestly no doesn't kill me I made peace
with it I paid my money I paid whatever
iota I've reached out to her ten times
you know I could get on a plane and go
to where she lives and harass her that's
not something I want to do that's not
something I wouldn't want to be turned
around Island come on the papers and now
people mad at me cuz I harassed my
daughter I just did what I did with
everything else in my life
time time time has impatient and as much
of a [__]
and all the [__] faults I had when I
got into calmly I can't even tell you
that when I came here in 98 I looked
around I asked questions I kept my ears
open I listened I made friends with
people who knew the business like Rick
Rick Dunkleman and you know Rick do come
in and old the comic said let the store
Allan Stevens gave me guidance
you know Rogan and I were a couple years
apart so at this time Rogan was learning
the ropes too I was learning from him
and he was learning from me but I was
learning from asking people like Paul
Mooney blah blah blah blah blah blah and
everybody had me with the same answer it
was time they all said the same thing
put your head down keep getting on stage
and keep writing keep getting on stage
keep writing go to acting class
let's get an agent all these things will
make you strong and eventually you'll
get to the place where you want to be is
it gonna take a year or is it gonna take
ten years you never [__] know that's
why all you could do is put your head
down and keep doing what works this is
what works well frustration go away
listen man I get frustrated when I get
in the car and I'm on the 405 but as
soon as I realize where I'm going what
I'm doing the purpose and I'm out I like
that it could be all worse I could be
going in and get fired or I'll be going
to turn myself in or something
I realize I have nothing to be
frustrated about frustration is
something we add on ourselves because
when I door was supposed to be [__]
doing you know for years I was
frustrated with my wife my ex-wife why
would that be frustrated frustrated my
ex-wife I wasn't doing what I was
supposed to be doing and trust me
once you start doing the things that
you're supposed to do yes I write my
goals every day but I also write the
three things I need to do every day
the three things to reach to that goal
every day I got a show tonight what
great things are to do have to look at
my material I have to pick up my shirt
whatever the [__] you want to write you
write down I don't give a [__] what you
write down as long as you write it down
the three things you need to do today
not to be frustrated how can I not be
half of it and I'm telling you this is
from [__] I'm an expert in being
frustrated expert you know a couple
weeks ago I got stuck at the airport
with Steve Simone we the flight got
canceled to Atlanta I'm sorry the show
got rescheduled for the 25th of January
to Tabernacle see that we couldn't get a
date earlier that I wanted a Saturday
because I know a lot of people were
driving out there so please just bear
with me we got stuck at the [__]
Airport and when they cancelled off
flying at 5 o'clock I gotta tell you
some some always get a little agitated
and I had to put my hand on his shoulder
and calm him down and it was that he was
fresh but you know you get frustrated
but I didn't get frustrated
we're 20 years ago I would have been a
[__] mess
and did I lose money I lost money I lost
money I'm the [__] hotel I lost money
from the ticket sales I wasn't the least
bit frustrated because it was way beyond
my control
do you know how to fly a plane Joey no
do you know how to fly a plane Steve so
no then there's nothing to do it's a
seven-hour drive to Atlanta it's 5
o'clock we're not gonna [__] make it
you could be mad or you could adjust
then I came home and I spoke to my
neighbor and my neighbor was taking a
flight from Haiti that day and he was
gonna land in Atlanta and take
connecting flight to LA and they
grounded him in [__] Atlanta and I go
how did you feel he goes nothing there's
nothing you could do or you could do is
[__] he goes I win I got a cab I got
a hotel room when I went to a jazz blue
bar and got drunk he was it's all I
could do because they lost my luggage
too from Haiti I don't know if this is
the same rebirth for me whatever like if
something bad happens like if we get a
flat tire or your plane gets canceled I
get I don't get the stress as much as
when I have too many options because
when something bad happens you're right
like this is like I can't change this
you can't change so that to me that's
not as frustrating as like oh it's
delayed it might come work oh there's
traffic on the way to the gig like that
for me is when I get more frustrated
those little things those are things
you're gonna get frustrated about for a
couple of minutes you know I'm talking
about when you're frustrated like when
you you know when life files on like a
piles on you know I wouldn't have been
if I would have been a little frustrated
with my life I would have thrown a clip
[__] at that plane ticket okay at that
counter and that tells me a lot like
when I left and I went back to the hotel
room like on the flight home the next
day I thought about by my behavior I
thought about how 20 years has affected
my behavior you know not even 10 years
has affected my behavior because once
once I stopped doing the coke
to picture filled-in like I always would
looked at a picture but it didn't have
the colors put in it was just a blank
piece of paper with designs and and
outlines and whatnot once I stopped
doing drugs that killed 10,000
frustrations it really did I started the
frustration of my ex-wife I still had
the frustration of a career of not
moving along as fast as I want because
we all want things to come right away I
see it when you guys send me messages I
see it when I read post on it we all
expect something right to [__] away
and if we don't get it right away you
know god forbid the world hates me I got
no luck no look at it from the other way
look at it what you can do not to speed
up the process but to make sure you're
taking the right steps to get unfuckin
frustrated so you're not frustrated so
you could do whatever the [__] you're
doing without that burden that burden
when you lose that burden from your
shoulders you can't even believe it you
think like if something's going on am I
taking new vitamins it's a new shampoo
you know I got a new girlfriend no no no
no you let the frustration that you had
to go you're gonna sleep better you
gonna be a better friend you're gonna be
a better boyfriend a better husband
you're gonna be so much better and so
many [__] different avenues it's
gonna shock you you know what the [__]
was that frustrated about and then
you're gonna answer question number two
I knew all along this day would come
whether you want to get married whether
you want to sell the house whether you
want to build a house whatever plan you
had to go that was getting you
frustrated once you accomplish it you go
what the [__] was I frustrated about
this was gonna happen anyway I stopped
snort in 2007 and I had gotten a lot of
movies till 2004 when I got the longest
yard that took a big frustration off my
shoulders because now and let me know
that I could do
what well for two reasons number one I
never thought I could get into a movie
but there was always that little 2
percent belief that I could get in the
movie and when I got in the movies even
though I had shot spider-man 2 and taxi
and all a bunch of movies by then this
particular movie let me know that that 2
percent was right even though I had 98%
against me and I was never frustrated
guys I can tell you that right off the
bat if you think I'm frustrated because
I can't get on Jimmy Kimmel in one of
those shows you're absolutely wrong
because I decided early on that I knew I
wouldn't work on those shows and I was
absolutely right I was absolutely right
I've never worked on one of those shows
my comedy would never work it would
never work for me because whatever you
saw when you come to see me at the store
I'm the drive there I might think of
something else and say it and now you'll
be pissed at me and you'll never put me
back on so before we even get to that
I'll just eliminate it I don't want to
be on your [__] show I know I'm not a
clean spotless clean comic the do I want
to work like that so I never had those
frustrations I had frustration of the
month I'm going to Montreal to the dirty
show that's a frustrating thing how can
I not get invited to the Montreal dirty
show but eventually I realized it wasn't
going to make a big difference if I went
and the frustration one away you just
said something that you have to make the
decisions justly don't be so you're not
frustrated but what the thing that I
worry about is like you will you talk
about like 10 years ago you almost quit
to sell cars to me that seems like a
decision out of frustration that's not
really fixing the frustration you have
so like what how do you stop yourself
from making the the car selling this is
2009 when I got married I moved up here
to the valley
my wife was making good money I had got
a couple deals a couple video show
stations and stuff like that I had you
know done My Name Is Earl I'd done a
bunch of [__] rhogam was paying me well
on the road well now what
with him and when I went out without
Rogan I made a regular road money which
I did not mind you know I was okay in
2009 when I decided that I wanted to
sell cars it was it was not a
frustration it wasn't no it was me
coming to terms with me I had given it a
New York run I I got my movies I got the
headline I was never gonna go to
Montreal I didn't even know about
Netflix then there are these specials
like that I thought it was more of a
give up okay and it wasn't really gonna
be a give up I was just gonna do comedy
in Los Angeles okay that's it
but that wasn't out of frustration I
didn't know no not at all I didn't know
about the Comedy Store then I thought I
would never go back The Improv still
gave me spots I had my room and brayer I
was doing fine I was doing fine I was
not a frustration it was out of I didn't
know how to get to the next level and at
that point I didn't want to go I was
pretty happy where I was okay if it
meant I just saw a lot of things I saw a
lot of things and headliners especially
Ralphie and I saw a lot of people
changing and how their priorities
changed and a bunch of stuff change but
I saw it a negative change a lot of
people and I thought that if I had to do
that every week like that I would change
and I was very happy I was very happy
walking my and those days they used to
walk my wife to the train in the morning
and then I would walk around the
neighborhood a little Gulman right for a
few hours and then every other weekend
every two weekends I was opening up for
Joe and then I would pick up a weekend
somewhere on my own once a month and I
would fly there for 1,500 bucks or
something like that you know and my
plane ticket would be like four and it
didn't really bother me because I kept
my low overhead low I wasn't out to
acting like a [__] gavone and me and
my wife had a great limb my wife made
good money
I didn't have to [__] kill myself I
just didn't think that I was ever gonna
get the chance to go on the road sell
tickets and have my I didn't see it
coming it wasn't a frustration move it
was just an honesty time oh okay I was
just being honest with myself there's
guys that do Konami who I've mentioned
before that when they wake up in the
morning oh you know what I love calmly I
love watching Netflix specials I love
doing an open mic every Monday to see
the guys and I like doing one week in
the month I could my job gives me a
Thursday off the take off and these guys
you see him they got a smile on their
face and they're very content what do
you think that there weren't other
talented guys on the Seattle when I left
all those guys stayed in Seattle in that
content or what they do I'm not mad at
them they knew what they wanted to do
and they stuck to their plan you know
what I'm gonna live in the Pacific
Northwest
I'm gonna go to hi-de-ho I'm gonna go to
Oregon I'm gonna go to Northern
California and I'll go to you know five
states surrounding me I got plenty of
one-nighters up here and I'm raising a
family
some people know where they stand that's
why I always tell people be careful what
you wish for because you just might get
it before you make that wish write down
what exactly you want what exactly it is
that you want you want to raise your
family won't have enough time for your
mom you will have enough time for you
for your kids you know what is it
exactly that you want to do there's a
lot of people I knew especially in
Denver I could tell you this I could
[__] countyman and fingers guys that
I did open mics with that told me to my
face like I don't want to do that I have
a day job I make great money I have
great insurance I like coming here on
Mondays I go to this place Club
fifty-two on Wednesdays to get away from
my wife and workout material and these
guys are the type of guys that get good
they get really good and they become
writers for the other guys the bigger
comics and
so they make a little scratch that way
but these guys don't ask for much they
don't want you could go up to them go
listen I got a gig for your Madison
Square Garden I don't want it
Wow about opening for move it I don't
really want and I gonna have to leave on
a Thursday and I'm glad to get a sitter
for my kid
they have already predetermined what
type of career they have I have a friend
that's a professional musician and I
grew up with a kid that has a bar band
he's my age 55 years old he has a great
band called the past masters they do
haul covers of songs they do weddings
they do bars they do racetracks they're
one of the most popular bands in New
Jersey that's how he wants it he's an
engineer they take the summers off so do
you think that do you think that where
someone like like Rudy Sarzo might be
frustrated if that was his life because
he wanted more but because these people
knew what they wanted there's no
frustration if you know what you want
ahead of time don't be no frustration if
you write it down you're comfortable
with it you know and it's like let's say
something else happens then something
else happens it's a cherry on the
[__] sundae it's a cherry on the
[__] sundae but frustration is
something you have to look at because
frustration comes next or anger and then
on top of that mixed with anger they
throws doubt in your next move so but
that main character is frustration you
have to get him out of the way then the
anger will disappear and the down--all
disappear and that's that's when you
cooking with gas like once my
frustrations ended like in 2008 when I
put all the pieces together that's when
I knew I was I was on to something but
then I decided you know what I really
just want to do like a TV show for a
long time I love going to CBS Rev that's
my all-time favorite if you don't shoot
the show at CBS Radford I don't want to
be there it's right around the corner
the traffic ain't bad you can walk they
got good food on there [__] nice
people
somebody sees your walk and they pull
over the shuttle get stuck at Fox see if
somebody pulls all
[__] shuttles money over the ride
don't run you the [__] over it's 2,000
degrees you're walking around with a
parka shoot you're playing a [__]
Australian [__] Eskimo is over to
give you a [__] ride so but that's
not the point the point was that I don't
know I didn't know mercy was coming
nobody knew mercy was coming I was just
happy with my wife being a couple and I
enjoyed opening up for Rogan I enjoy how
he treated me I knew what my position
was on that team I was gonna get that
[__] audience crowd the [__] up up
front and be his filthy and his [__]
good as I could so he could follow it
with a bang and I was happy doing that
and I could see that Club as one
wouldn't let me do that as a feature act
for that there was no way what I was
doing in front of Rogan what clubs allow
all the headliners in love first of all
six out of ten headliners couldn't
follow it what I would throw in this
boat things and I wasn't as consistent
as I am now in those days I was like
6040 once I stopped doing coke
I turned 70/30 8020 in front of Rogan I
could see the improvement in 2013 right
before mercy I started having doubts
about stand-up again really I did a
couple bad shows and I'm like maybe I
should have stuck to my guns but it was
just fine yet to get on stage more well
I had mercy in the beginning I wasn't
getting on stage for a long periods of
time and then Rogan would ask me to do a
gig and I just stink up the [__]
joint you know I just think it the [__]
up then I figured out how to work around
having a daughter how to write and all
the pieces worked out and even now you
don't see me after a show you'll go hon
how was a good show I taped it for you
or whatever I'm frustrated for a second
but I'm frustrated with me I'm never
frustrated with the audience
I'm never frustrated with the venue it's
always something I did well the [__]
guy heckled me and the bar guy didn't
throw him out well if your material
would have been on boy he wouldn't act
right so can you sense what if you sense
frustration are you like okay this is
coming and I need to change something
yes especially with stand-up the British
frustration we have of life is not
taking responsibility for our actions
that's what frustration is born not
taking responsibility it's this guy's
fault that's guys for it's my boss's
fault it's his comedians fault it's the
world's fault it's the street fault
no that's that's how frustration starts
by not taking responsibility for
yourself one day when you know I I don't
want to feel like this no more what do I
need to do not to feel like this normal
boom it hits you like a [__] overhand
right like I need to write five days
instead of four days I need to get on
stage I know for a fact that Heinz
personally need five sets a week to stay
sharp so when I stay home during a week
I need five sets a week to stay sharp
that's two sets tonight one on Thursday
and two on Saturday or vice versa I play
his own defense two to one on Saturday
nothing could stop me from doing those
five sets
I need five sets when I was doing comedy
for years I needed I would go for 15
spots every week fourth year once I
moved to Seattle or none I was on to 15
spots a week two on Friday two on
Saturday right and and I'd go somewhere
like I'd go to the main one and then I
go to a bar and I get onstage whether
they had a microphone that just to hit
that number how what happens or how do
you like if you're frustrated like okay
this is this is what's holding me back
if it's something that you struggle with
like we were talking before the show
I've always been a shy person and for me
to get bar shows I need to just start
going and hanging out without having a
purpose and to be honest that makes me
nervous and I really did something the
other day there was a thing by Bruce Lee
okay
he said no limits right I think
myself and D'Agostino touched on this
the other day for you to become a good
comic everything about you has to change
like your beliefs have to change if
you're shy too bad you know the saying
if you don't like Knights too bad if you
don't like sleeping in hotels too bad if
you don't like sleeping in your car too
bad that all changed we discussed that
the other day that once you make the
crossover into being a comedian you
could dry with a certain disable sticker
you're not right somewhere somewhere the
circuitry is not right uh-huh
so why are you trying to to play it off
like the circuitry is right who the [__]
are you to say you're not gonna I'm sure
I don't want to go down there well this
is not gonna work weed this is not gonna
work for you you're a comedian you can't
be shot I could see you being
introverted Chris Rock is very
introverted but you can't be shy you're
a comedian
you gotta tell that [__] in the front
row she got a big set of titties it's
different on stage but so how do you or
how did you work on things like like the
drug thing like that's that's an easy
thing to say I'm gonna quit drugs but
you had tried before
I tried 35 times I tried 35 times too
but it's the same thing as a diet you
tried 38 days in her own eventually to
my clique it all comes together as a
machine you know it all comes figure if
I say to you when you have to make an
investment in something it's completely
different it's completely different when
I went on my little fad diets I used to
go on nothing would happen once I said
that's it my spot at the store is 11:30
I'm embarrassed to go to the Y at 400
pounds at 6:00 I'll go at 9:00 and I
forced myself to go to Y every night at
[__] nine o'clock you know what I
didn't want to do I forced myself to do
you know when I had Jackie on Sundays
and Wednesdays I would have to they
would come and I would have to meet her
at his parking lot and I left there and
I would have to give her away and give
her a kiss and tell her I loved it all
in two days and when
would turn around and walk back to my
car tears would stream down my face now
what was the last time you were crying
and you felt like doing copy not really
not really nobody wants to do comedy
this is a devastating thing my little
daughter I won't see it too Wednesday
these scumbags are holding a hostage on
me I did that I felt bad for maybe three
weeks frustration centered and then I
said how do I not feel this way I'm
Wednesday nights get up off your fat
[__] ass and get to an open mic or
club or somewhere you're not going up go
down it and I would roll the joint and
leaving in the ashtray we get in the car
I'd cry I'd wipe my tears and when they
would pull away with their [__] I
wouldn't open up the ashtray right there
in the Safeway parking lot and I would
smoke the joy I pick up my chin a little
bit I look in the mirror I double-check
my eyeballs and I go you're gonna go out
to a club now and do comedy
I don't give a [__] how bad you feel and
I did it you know
the night and guess what that year of me
doing that trained me for February when
I went to sit on the plane in Burbank
and I got a call at 4 o'clock that Brody
Stevenson hung himself you know how many
comics had to go on stage that night
with that thought that Brody Stephens
had to go on but they're professionals
yeah
some companies what a drag oh my god
it's ashamed he was so positive let's
have a [__] drink but there was other
comics that had a job to do that night
comics that were close with Stephen
Brody Brody Stephens and his [__]
name has got arrested so they were close
with Brody Stephens I've never gone to
the hotel room and Kate thought so bad I
said come over we'll just eat here and I
just ordered a bunch of food and we ate
in the room and then we all went down
together nobody wanted to be alone
that's how bad everybody felt in that
room
but we had to perform when I got
downstairs
I felt bad I felt like crying the whole
[__] night but my body and my mind
wouldn't let me these people paid $40 to
[__] see me on stage in Vegas it's
not a 20-hour ticket in Vegas it's like
a $48 ticket and [__] ticket fees and
[__] right so I had no time to bleed
that's what that expression is called
you got no time to bleed I don't have
five days to bleed and we went up with
it that was from me training myself in
1995 for a whole year instead of crying
like a [__] and being angry and
figuring out who I was like kill
cornered ookami took care of all that
[__] it was amazing
going down there going on stage bombing
drinking a cocktail took care of all
that [__] and made that frustration go
away because they let me know I could do
it I guess I could do it I don't know
what it meant but it let me know like
what some can do it it's uh it's wild
that that that something like that would
make you feel better like it seems like
you could be like okay if I bomb it's
gonna make me feel worse you know man
Vaman getting a standing ovation doing
good
getting applause brace it's all the same
thing really
you still got up on stage that's true in
my world you still got up on stage I
don't like the Francis O'Donnell fight
on Saturday he nicked Junior dos Santos
you know I thought jr. could have fought
better I thought jr. was thinking better
Fighting's are better than fighter
Justin getting in the cage I give those
people props yeah I'm not the type of
guy the guy Frieza baumann you know what
bro at the end of the day just him
training for six weeks and getting into
the cage he deserves something yeah you
win you get frustrated you see the hand
coming bah bah bah
what is frustration mean now I'm gonna
do something different I won't be in
this position
right okay and then it's on the other
side of it is okay I got a standing
ovation I should just do it like this
every time and you try even if you try
it sometimes it doesn't like it's hard
to like repeat things sometimes that's
why you start brand new fresh every day
cuz whatever happened yesterday happened
yesterday I don't give a [__] about what
happened last night
it's over so bombed did well didn't
mediocre but let's be honest I bombed in
New Orleans three weeks ago it still
haunts me it's really gotta go down
there next year and light that room on
[__] fire
did I really bomb no I just didn't do as
well as I had I could do what what am i
frustrated for not doing as well as I
did I wrote down what things I did wrong
when I went up there it wouldn't happen
again that's at the 28 year mark anomaly
cuz I don't like being [__]
frustrated right so if you're frustrated
that's you know and it goes back to my
daughter you know from all those years I
didn't get her and I blamed everybody I
blame this guy blame my ex-wife I blame
the boyfriend and blamed the court
system and then I realized and guess
what in 95 even if I beat the court case
and whatever I'm a [__] comic how
much time do I have to raise a child I
mean at that time I was a [__] Road
Dogg guys now I'm an older guy I'm a
different realm of comedy things are
different I put my time in but at that
time for what I was looking to do I was
looking to be on stage every night to
speed up this process to become a better
comic at the four year mark I didn't
want Fame I didn't want money I didn't
want anything I gotta be honest with you
guys I wanted to be a tremendous [__]
comic I could look you all in the eye
and tell you that throughout this comedy
career
I tell Lee all the time if you're
looking to make money it'll sell kilos
ago if that's what you're looking for
you're not gonna find it here
you know I get calls from people all the
time but I have known on and off for
friends of friends all of a sudden they
want to start a podcast cuz there's
money in it I know it's a failure you
just said the wrong words to me you just
said the wrong words to me tell me that
you wanna start a podcast to inform
people about comedy or inform people
about cancer or your road to cancer or
how to avoid anything but don't tell me
you'd want to start a podcast for money
because 90% of the time you're gonna
fail you gotta be depressed none of this
[__] that you're starting is for money
yes down the line you hope that you
figure out how to turn what you're doing
whether it's would work rather you know
I got a bottle at the house I got this
bottle that I bought 20 years ago it's
an old wine bottle and an artist put
postage stamps on it he went to an old
[__] thing cut out postage stamps so
it's whenever were posted stamps you
know I bought that bottle from that guy
20 years ago now I'm talking about 1998
no it was 96 no there was 98 I was doing
gay pride in Michigan and I walked the
next day there was a car fare and I went
for a walk and this guy was like I'm
writing a book right now and I got I
called this guy the bottle books guy
he's one of the angels that came into my
life to give me a message I was walking
down the thing they had paid me like a
thousand bucks for this game festival I
had never seen a thousand I hadn't seen
a thousand bucks
this was 98 I hadn't seen a thousand
bucks at one time and one check was just
like 1991 Wow like I was in [__]
heaven I was scared to even cash the
check
that's how I had not seen a check for
$1,000 in [__] nine years and I had
this loose money and I walked to the
scene on the farmers markets but they
have bizarre athon
they sell different wares and [__] and
this guy was selling bottles for some
reason you know like you look at all
these things there was a booth that had
tamales and there was a booth that at
different juices and there was a boot
that they painted your face and there
was a boot that sold olives there was
all these boots of crabs but this guy
really stuck out he had to be around 48
maybe 50 he had been smoking a cigarette
since the womb you could tell him when
his mother used to smoke cigarettes in
the fifth grade
but he was a tremendous artist he took
these bottles all types of bottles you
know wine bottles beer bottles the one I
bought is like one of those Hennessy
Bibles and he put the tape then he put a
glaze over it and it just looked neat I
looked at what the guy had done like oh
you know what that looks neater how much
you want for the bomb he's like 20 bucks
listen if you think I had 20 bucks to
give this [__] schmuck but before I
gave him the 20 we talked for probably
two hours and we talked about the arts
and we talked about when he started
making these bottles he would pay for
the boot out of his own pocket for the
first four years or five years I think
it was three and a half years he said he
paid the booth rental a hundred dollars
every Saturday for 14 weeks out of his
own pocket
he had a day job to believe in those
[__] bottles and he said that he had
been there for three and I go how many
bottles with yourself you know like a
week like on a weekend he'd go to 20
bucks a bottle he was still losing a
couple hundred a month he was telling me
and he goes that one Saturday he did
something he put a balloon up and he he
paid an extra twenty five bucks even
though he was getting ripped off he paid
an extra twenty five bucks to get closer
to the to the entrance and he put
lollipops in the thing and nine he was
selling 20 bottles every [__] week
you know so what did he do he was
frustrated and that's where I learned
that from he goes I didn't quit he goes
I just made my product better can I make
my product better he goes no my
advertisement had to be
my marketing had to be better so I had
to get closer to the entrance so when
people got the full $20 I get it before
they spend it on carrots and [__]
artichokes and [__] plus I made my booth
more friendly I put balloons around it
I put whatever now all that money that I
lost I've already made back in one year
what you know now guess what I had been
doing that type of [__] at the Sheraton
when I was 21 years old remember I told
you about a year ago I used to buy up it
was a happy hour slice to buy food after
half the half the price when you bartend
haven't pulled out for the merchants
right and next thing you know my money
went up my [__] 100 bucks
so I was frustrated but I figured out a
way and that's what all this is when
you're frustrated when you're frustrated
with something is that you're not
figuring out what you're doing that's
all that is it's just an emotion that
you're not taking care of you have to
take care of something for that emotion
to go away like I said to you today I'm
low louis c.k I'm no Chris Rock no Jo
koy but I am frustrated either I am
frustrated at all by no means
and my frustrating my career why because
I know I do my job every day every day I
do exactly what I have to do doing those
things I don't like doing I don't like
it
so in this scenario do you see yourself
getting to that higher level or you just
content where you are I'm so happy right
now
I'm content on where I am I don't really
give a [__] I don't want to do I have to
[__] these people do if I have to do
half of what these people want to I
don't want my bombs to come up on TMZ
right you know that's our saying I don't
want my bombs coming up on TMZ I don't
want every move that I do being analyzed
by anybody I don't want somebody going
walk 20 years ago he did it I don't want
it I don't want that really doesn't
matter what I did 30 years ago
it's what I'm doing today
and how I'm living my life today that's
all that [__] matters if I was still
mammogram and snorting coke and robbing
people that's one day I love how I'm
living today I love that I get to do
this show connect with people in a
certain way and then go on the road and
connect with them in a different way to
me it's a game it's a game of chess I
love it I could raise my prices to $69
and do this
I see the prices these people are
charged on the road and it makes me sick
to my [__] stomach because they've
forgotten all about the American
household and how hard it is to keep a
job you know it's it's bad enough you
gotta go see a baseball game and get
[__] in the ass with your kids and how
you want to go see a comic so I try to
keep I'm not here to rob nobody I robbed
enough I just want people to have a
[__] the same good time that I'm
having
I want people to feel the same thing I'm
feeling awful one joint and going on
stage before I go on stage there's no
hablo it's just a half a joint I put it
out and I go up then I giggle like a
[__] [__] and I'd you know jump up and
down I say dirty jokes and I say Jost I
rub people the wrong way but to me I'm
having a good time if this means me
having a good time just what would be
bad me me having to get on stage every
night me having to deliver the 20,000
people every day that paid 150 or
[__] ticket me having to have a
[__] bodyguard and an assistant and a
[__] road manager following me
everywhere me having to have like
somebody wake me up and I don't want
that that's something that's was never
for me you know when I see people with
assistants I'm gonna jump off a [__]
bridge unless you're [__] you know
unless you're [__] my pet and even
then the president you know and even
that unless you're a scientist you know
that you need to I don't get it it's not
for you I don't want 20 people around me
in the day no you know me emails I get
from people hey man can you train me to
help you I don't know how to train
somebody I don't know how to stop and go
back and try it you can't
I can't train people to what I do what I
do how I do it is completely different
than other people do it you know I like
to save on time I like the same energy
I gotta get gas I coulda came over here
earlier [__] that I come over here when
I had to doing a podcast a lot of people
who came well you know I like to write
out my day you know I'd only if I don't
need to go that when I go to Hollywood I
go to Hollywood well I go to Hollywood I
stop with five places you know I'm
saying I stop over here I say oh I drop
something off here but no I'm very happy
where I am I'm very happy going on the
road twice a month they push bigger
venues on to me and a bunch of this [__]
and I refuse it I'm very happy I have to
accept Who I am in 57 years old
I have a daughter what I really really
want to be a part of our life and raise
her and I enjoy coming in here and doing
this with you twice a week this doesn't
burn me out everything I do cannot burn
me up I've been burnt out for years I
don't I don't want to be burnt out again
I don't mix and match I don't put myself
in bad predicaments like do a movie and
tell San Antonio in Dallas I'm gonna be
there I would have never got that my
manager might not my manager what my
booking agent thought I could have got
there I know things happen and now you
you know cuz i have made Detroit and
Omaha work may 16th and 17th and 18th I
would have made all my ha work going
back now Detroit when I had to get
cancelled anyway San Antonio and Dallas
would know how to get cancelled at the
end of the week that needs to be
canceled but I worked that Thursday and
Wednesday what if there a crane would
have broke on Thursday and I would have
to come back on Friday the shoot that I
would have had to cancel Dallas today up
so so now so now the question is is do
you and it seems like the answer is yes
but how do you live your life to like
not even get rid of frustration but to
avoid like future frustration do we
to do the first time correctly before
you make that move
think about that move and if you're
gonna commit to this make sure you're
giving it a hundred percent of what you
got because if you give it eighty you're
gonna be frustrated if you give it
ninety you're gonna be frustrated and if
you give it ninety six percent you're
gonna be frustrated you've got to give
it a hundred and ten percent so there's
never a doubt let's let it be honest
with you and let me be honest the
listeners on the end they will wrap it
up I don't need to open up a notebook if
you remember my story at all when I went
to prison I got on stage like ten times
and then one of the guys came up to me
he goes here take a notebook you don't
need to write your jokes and I said to
him I don't write jokes I go on stage
and I get hot and I told him about what
bothers me and the guy goes you do that
without writing I like oh yeah I went to
Murray tea this morning I wrote for an
hour and a half
I mostly stuff around I moved a couple
words around I eliminated a sentence I
put a couple I put a paragraph in the
book you know I drank some tea I got
some vitamin D I got to be a side and I
got to be honest with people listening
if I did what Jo koy did I'd be a lot
better of a comic what do you mean I
don't just don't even use a notebook oh
no no no okay
like he writes on the road on the stage
got a guy on stage I write better on
stage I know this for a fact when I'm
with you [__] around when we were
here the other day talking [__] we're
talking about the Jews and blocking and
huh the pigeons at the Jews fall I tried
to do that [__] again yes they were my
wife it didn't work Oh didn't work she
looked at me like I wasn't even funny
so I know in my heart that I could throw
away my notebook just save it to write
down the blueprint but I would do a lot
better as a writer with 800 eyes
everything is different when you write
some when you write someone a piece of
paper and when you got a right when 800
people looking at you hate on you
through there's four other people to
rule you got ain't a hundred eyes right
right well you got a hundred eyes
looking I hear you right quick Jack yeah
that's the best material I wrote like
this week I added two tags to a joke in
D'Agostino reminded me or Steve Simone
reminded me at night because I've never
heard that before
and I felt like saying to him you know I
couldn't save that to my heart I
couldn't go ha ha ha ha yeah I just
wrote that last night I didn't I wrote
that on stage it was just an impact
thing that came I did it to kilt
just a line just to add a line to it I
love when people go oh my god I've never
heard you say that before
well you're [__] [__] because I
haven't yeah what so that that's
annoying to me and I guess maybe
actually you just accept it whenever I
sit down and try to write something
almost never work no get high go with
your friends and pick a topic let them
throw top again not not like free right
determined I'm talking about saying you
just show up and see six guys in the
pizza place and you're eating and
awesome this pizza tastes like [__] I
hate to explicitly write this like this
Pete you know and then BOOM oh [__]
you should say it on stage now you got
something work with God you got a line
to work with that you know you can't
beat that at all
I do a lot better on stage but for me to
sleep at night I gotta sit down put the
work in and put the work in a little bit
just to make me believe that I'm putting
in the work even though I know I go to
the comedy store tonight and I got two
sets and the set out doing the mainland
when I walked into the original am I
gonna do and by the time I woke with the
original oh I'll get rid of a wine that
I didn't like or I'll add that bit
somewhere else I'll do that and come
home and go woof I did my [__] job
this week right and that's what I do
even though I don't need to do it I
could just be lazy and go [__]
notebook
[__] Murray tea but ever since I wrote I
read writing by Stephen King you have to
sit down every day
you have to sit down at a certain time
every day force yourself after nobody
wants to sit down nobody wants to sit on
them right it's the hardest thing in the
world you start forcing yourself
guess what now then I created an
addiction feel weird if y'all do it now
I feel weird if I don't do it and that's
exactly how I wanted to feel that's
exactly how I wanted to feel let me tell
you what the worst thing in the world is
I'm 56 years old and I lift weights and
I do a couple other things if I wake up
and I'm sure and I had plans I'm going
to boxing Muay Thai
I won't go cuz I'm really so that's one
thing that's one thing when I get up and
I go on thank God and go hey my back we
did a bunch of kicks or we care about
flings or whatever if I don't go just
because I don't want to go because I'm
[__] around I can't live with myself
the rest of the day our bomb on stage
that night Wow that's how bad it is
because I forced myself comedy life life
in general
to make your life easier and not be
frustrated life in general is doing the
things you don't want to do when you see
a [__] girl on a porno taking it up
the ass you think she five out of those
ten girls do you really think they want
to be there probably not their faces
yeah but they got a hungry kid right
they never thought that well let
somebody [__] him in the ass for the
small thousand dollars but they got a
kid they got a husband through them how
to abuse them and they gotta go now buy
a place don't get me wrong some of them
are pigs and ones the biggest yes and
what America siege is coming out of
their [__] ass haha but I guarantee
five of those women go home and cry
themselves to sleep at night it's a sad
thought but it's true do you know how
many times I cried myself to sleep when
we're doing something I didn't want to
do because I had a [__] do it for the
money time to time tons of times and
every time I washed a dish and a [__]
restaurant every time I bust the table
every time I put a brick down you know
every time a boy
she yelled at me ah so the lesson we
learned today on the fourth of July is
if you don't want to be [__]
frustrated doing a [__] work
that's it and that's that you know does
the work
[__] Americans give yourselves
a round of applause for being a [__]
Americans now on you gotta think of this
[__] podcast and go what the [__] was
he talking about what I'm talking about
is this Worr [__] Americans God
Buddha Allah whoever the Karma life
itself they all had a [__] plan for
you you know how you know because you're
not one of those [__] the migrants
trying to jump the fence in Mexico
you're not a black kid in Africa with
flies on you or you're not in [__]
Iran right now fearing for your life
that America is gonna bomb you they put
you here on this [__] country
you understand me the United States of
America that means you have the
opportunity everybody else has so stop
feeling [__] bad for yourself grab
your [__] balls salute the flag while
painting the hotdogs with your family
and happy fourth of July to all you
[__] thank you for listening
and I'll be back Monday morning tip-top
Magoo no Tuesday morning we got one of
the guys the Foo Fighters next week it's
gonna be a good week but I want to let
you guys know have a great holiday
weekend don't play with [__]
fireworks don't get caught I mean listen
I ain't mad at you gotta play the
[__] fireworks from time to time why
the five I can throw over a wall just
don't throw that animals and [__] like
that all right I love you guys all my
heart but before we leave a little
message from our sponsors first up both
of these companies are my family number
one CBD lion calm listen there's a lot
of fakes out there there's a lot of
people bullshitting there's a lot of
people selling [__] Fugazi Zout there
don't be one of those [__] [__]
if you don't know the product why the
[__] do you give this somebody money you
know what I know you you know me you
know where to find me you know where
I've been
okay I got no reason to lie to you
[__] like I said I'm 56
I'm out of nut juice the testosterone
levels are down but you know what I
still try to put it in four days a week
and it's [__] tough and you know who
I thank for that
CBB lion calm listen picking a reliable
company used to be like [__]
getting [__] in the ass on one of
those boards but no more uncle Joey's
here he found CBD line for you
they make CBD products from start to
finish it's not outsourced it's not made
in [__] India right here
[__] they take care of it from
the beginning to the end they got you
covered now let's say you want Joey but
I like smoking my seed need my CBD I
like it innovate or I like it in the
shadow or I really don't like the [__]
in the shadow or the cartridges I want
to eat it in the gummy or maybe
attention they got you covered
Texas dummies shattered [__] pegs let
me tell you some I live off that 2500
milligram thing you just take that
little tension and put on your tongue to
be honest II you guys I'm a little
overweight as you've noticed so I take
two of those blasts listen I sleep like
a [__] baby you like to enjoy but I
sleep like a baby now yeah but I'm 56
years old and I pee every hour on the
hour I take two little things of those
things under my tongue CBD line I sleep
like a [__] baby I closed my eyes at
12:01 and I'm opening them up at like
7:15 in the morning that's what I'm
trying to say to you their products are
clean Bobby and they're like the face
and all these [__] places that have
false advertising you know why right now
if you want go to CBB Lion calm when you
go on that webpage the night just
selling you products they also have the
third party lab results that you could
check out yourself to confirm what I'm
[__] telling you no more [__]
witch products no more buying [__] from
[__] some discounted the credit line
some [__] website CBD line is the CBD
that you're looking for now today the
church family gets 20% off when they
press in church at checkout that CH you
are CH CBD Lyon has you covered
do you understand me if I was you you'd
like Joey what should I get the first
time get the raspberry [__] gummies
and get yourself some tension and call
me in a month and tell me how good you
feel you're gonna write me an email
going Joey you know what I was a little
[__] skeptical but I'm happy I want
with CBD line you will be happy you want
to see me do a line go to CBD line calm
right now
pressed Church in on checkout and you
get 20% off CBD Lyon the best of the
business also to my family and honor
they've been with us since day one I
loved their supplements he understand me
I live on the Alpha brain I live on the
shrimp export and before I got on a
plane I ate two of those [__] shrimp
that communes why because they work and
they backed their product alpha brain
that number one product if you don't
like it if it gives you a headache or
whatever the [__] you complain about
they'll give you your money back and
they don't want the product back who
does that nobody in the industry does
that go to audit calm right now
impressive Church on the way out look at
that great selection of supplements
whether you want to the oil they got
they just got some news et al the mCP or
they just got a new one either put it in
coffees or put in your milkshakes you
could do whatever you want for it going
on at that compress in church and get
10% off the Liberty house I want to
thank CBD Lyon I want to thank on it but
I want to thank you guys don't forget
Friday night I'm at the rec room in
Huntington Beach and then the 10th of
July through the 12th I'll be at the
Charlotte comedy zone so [__] enjoy
you dirty basses and that's it and
that's that we got a great week next
week I hope you have a great vacation
don't blow your fingers off and we'll
see you Tuesday morning nice and early
have a happy fourth of July it's a
beautiful day to be in America take this
[__] me only